en el vídeo donde hable de un impuesto
para las hamburguesas lo hice de un modo
un poco irreal porque utilicé un
impuesto que era una cantidad constante
en general los impuestos sobre el
consumo son un porcentaje del precio del
producto en cuestión por ejemplo podría
ser el 8 o 9 por ciento del precio de
venta
pensemos en la curva de oferta desde el
punto de vista del consumidor
veamos cómo afecta un impuesto
porcentual
bien supongamos que el gobierno pone un
impuesto porcentual en vez de uno fijo
haré un porcentaje alto para que sea
bastante claro el resultado digamos que
el impuesto es de
y 20 por ciento del precio 20 por ciento
del precio de cada hamburguesa se tiene
que pagar de impuestos como vimos
anteriormente para que los productores
comienzan a producir las primeras
hamburguesas necesitan recibir al menos
dos dólares por cada hamburguesa ese es
su costo de oportunidad de recibir menos
podrían usar los mismos recursos humanos
de obra en cualquier otra cosa algo que
quizás les deje una mayor ganancia así
que tenemos un costo mínimo de
oportunidad de dos dólares y mientras
más hamburguesas se produzcan el costo
de producción sube puesto que ahora los
recursos empleados quizás no sean tan
adecuados para producir hamburguesas o
quizás estén mejor destinados en otras
cosas así que el costo de producción de
las primeras hamburguesas es de 2
dólares
pero el consumidor ahora tiene que pagar
los dos dólares más el 20% de impuestos
que tienen las hamburguesas así que
desde el punto de vista del consumidor
hay que pagar 40 centavos adicionales y
así podemos ir construyendo una nueva
curva de oferta en azul ahora por acá
para que los productores produzcan algo
así como 2 millones y medio de
hamburguesas al día van a tener un costo
mayor para esta cantidad adicional para
que produzcan las 2 millones y medio de
hamburguesas diarias van a tener un
costo de alrededor de 3 dólares por cada
hamburguesa de nuevo desde el punto de
vista del consumidor entonces hay que
pagar el 20 por ciento de impuestos así
que los consumidores van a percibir que
el precio de la hamburguesa es de 3
dólares y 60 centavos y si ahora nos
vamos a donde el precio es de 4 dólares
que corresponde a una cantidad de 4
millones de hamburguesas por día
entonces los productores tienen un costo
de 4 dólares pero los consumidores por
el 20% de impuestos pagan 4 dólares con
80 centavos en general lo que observamos
es que desde el punto de vista del
consumidor la curva
oferta se ve algo así noten como ahora
ya no es un desplazamiento fijo sino que
el precio percibido es 20% mayor que el
precio sin impuestos entonces para
precios pequeños el cambio en el precio
percibido por el consumidor es menor
digamos el 20% de dos dólares es menor
que el 20% de tres dólares y el 20% de
tres dólares es menor que el 20% cuatro
dólares y así sucesivamente
así que mayor cantidad y mayor precio la
desviación de la curva es cada vez mayor
ya que el impuesto cada vez es más
grande en resumen la distancia entre la
curva nueva y la curva vieja ya no es un
valor constante pero siempre es el 20%
del precio anterior allí es el 20% y
allí está el 20% etcétera etcétera
etcétera el precio percibido por el
consumidor siempre es 20% más que el
costo de oportunidad de los productores
digamos por los 6 dólares los
consumidores tienen que pagar un dólar
con 20 centavos adicional pero en si el
fenómeno es el mismo que habíamos estado
observando previamente
todo estaría combinada es el superávit
de los productores y de los consumidores
pero ahora el punto de equilibrio se
movió ahora es ese punto que está en el
cruce con la nueva curva y entonces
tenemos una nueva cantidad de equilibrio
más o menos por ahí y ahora ni los
consumidores ni el gobierno ni los
productores van a poder acceder o
recibir una parte del superávit que
andaba por aquí cuando aún no habíamos
introducido el impuesto está es en sí la
razón por la cual el poner impuestos
generalmente se considera como algo
ineficiente obviamente es necesario en
cierta medida pero es ineficiente pues
reduce la actividad económica al menos
con las suposiciones del modelo y de
nuevo tenemos esta pérdida irrecuperable
de eficiencia es una parte del superávit
que ya no puede obtener nadie a que el
triangulito es la pérdida irrecuperable
de eficiencia y el gobierno de nuevo
obtiene una ganancia igual al área de un
rectángulo nuestra nueva cantidad
equilibrio es de cerca de 3 millones de
hamburguesas diarias que es parecido a
lo que obtuvimos en él
anterior la altura va a ser de 60
centavos el 20% de tres dólares así que
tenemos un rectángulo de altura igual a
60 centavos por hamburguesa y largo
igual a 3 millones de hamburguesas por
día así que el área es de 60 centavos
por hamburguesa que es el 20%
multiplicado por 3 millones de
hamburguesas esto nos da un total de 1.8
millones de dólares al día de ganancia
para el gobierno y como antes ahora el
superávit del productor se ha visto
reducido ahora el superávit del
productor va a hacer esta área de que
estoy dibujando justo por aquí y no sólo
eso también el superávit del consumidor
se ve afectado el superávit del
consumidor se redujo a ambos les quito
un cacho el impuesto y la pérdida
irrecuperable de eficiencia así que
tanto los productores como los
consumidores pierden